c'est un projet de loi de finance qui
sera ici débattu dans peu de jours qui
marque une très forte augmentation des
moyens consacrés au transport je me
permets d'y insister j'avais présenté
pour ce qui me concerne mon premier
budget de transport des transports l'an
dernier à peu près à la même époque
devant vous et c'était un budget qui
était en augmentation de 13 % par
rapport à l'année précédente la hausse
entre le projet de loi de finance entre
la loi de finance pardon pour 2023 et le
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 tel
qu'il vous est proposé est aussi de 13 %
ce qui veut dire qu'en 2 ans sur le
périmètre de l'ensemble des engagements
financiers de l'État en matière de
mobilité c'est une augmentation de près
de 30 % pour les transports vous le
savez la première ministre a annoncé
dans le cadre de la planification
écologique un renforcement des moyens
consacrés à la transition écologique de
7 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement 10 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement sur cette
hausse de 7 milliards d'euros les
transports représentent la plus
importante avec 1,6 milliards d'euros de
hausse c'est cela qui se retrouve dans
le PLF 2024 sur le périmètre consolidé
que j'évoquais puisque comme vous le
savez la vision d'ensemble n'est pas
toujours facile à restituer puisqu'il y
a à la fois le programme budgétaire le
plus directement concerné le programme
de3 et puis d'autres outils budgétaires
qui sont dans le budget lui-même ou les
satellites de l'État si je puis le
présenter ainsi à la fois d'autres
programmes je pense au bonus écologique
par exemple je pense aux aides à
l'aéronautique d'autre part et puis je
pense à l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures à la Société du Grand
Paris à certains budgets annexes et cet
effort complet qui représente pour le
PLF 2024 une proposition de 13,6
milliards d'euros de crédit donc encore
une fois une hausse de près de 30 % par
rapport à ce qu'il était il y a 2 ans
c'est un budget qui essaye qui je crois
il parvient de se concentrer sur les
grandes priorités que j'avais décrites
devant vous lors de mon arrivée à la
fois les transports du quotidien et la
décarbonation des transports de manière
transversale je ne m'étonnerai pas sur
tous les chiffres mais quand on regarde
cet effort global d'environ 13, 13
milliards et demi d'euros pour arrondir
il y a 8 milliards d'euros qui sont
directement consacrés aux mobilités
vertes principalement les transports
ferroviaires et collectif mais aussi le
transport fluvial ou l'effort national
en faveur du vélo 2 milliards d'euros
qui sont consacrés au verdissement de
secteurs fortement émetteur ou fortement
polluant je pense évidemment à l'aérien
et à la route et le reste qui est
consacé cré à la modernisation du réseau
routier c'est un point sur lequel le
Sénat est je le sais très engagé et très
vigilant et puis environ 1 milliard
d'euros qui est consacré à travers un
budget annexe à la modernisation et à la
sécurité de la navigation aérienne qui
est évidemment absolument prioritaire
avec des investissements qui sont
importants et qui nous remettront je le
crois au bon niveau en matière
d'investissement et de sécurité dans
notre contrôle aérien